today defiant in his first TV interview
in months the French president said he
had no regrets about his controversial
pension reform bill or forcing it
through the French Parliament by decree
this reform is necessary and I say this
is the French people I don't enjoy doing
this but it is out of a sense of Duty
that I committed to this
offered no concessions to opponents of
the reform he said he wouldn't reshuffle
his cabinet or change his prime minister
leaving some opposition and peace
unimpressed
symbolically defying France's working
class Mr mccrong has highlighted his
contempt for a part of the population
contempt that was the Hallmark of his
pensions Bill
France's trade unions say the reform is
unfair because it raises the retirement
age by two years to 64 and will have a
greater impact on poorer workers since
January they've LED strikes and protests
in the country against the reform in
Paris a strike by garbage collectors is
in its second week president macron will
certainly hope that the arguments that
he made in his television interview will
calm the situation and quell the
protests for now though that seems
unlikely
some students and teachers demonstrated
outside the higher education Ministry in
the city these teachers say the
government's ignoring people's concerns
the government is acting as if nothing
is happening on the streets and that as
if having millions of people protesting
peacefully doesn't mean anything and
doesn't change anything it's not just an
education issue it's all public services
which are being really destroyed by
these neoliberal policies today so this
rage has stacked up and now people are
claiming the streets because there's no
other way to be heard today
Trade union leaders hope the continued
protests will put pressure on the
government to scrap its reform for now
there's no indication that the president
will back down Blackwell says the reform
will help sustain the pension system for
future generations and he wants it to be
signed into law soon Natasha Butler Al
Jazeera Paris